damage but they've lost him and it's
twists alone in the 1v3 dupree with the
kill and astralis grab that 16th they
take the third and that does mean that
they've done it i actually have a
an announcement to make um that was
actually my last
games with team liquid listen this is
happening and yeah it sucks in a lot of
ways and wish it didn't have to be this
way i i guess when you know like when
the impending doom of something right
when you know it's it's there and things
aren't going well you don't have that
same necessity to keep things together
right and that not only goes for you but
for everybody else twist without liquid
what the hell is that there's the opener
twist a lot of pressure is on you now
the fate of phase resides on twist and
he's not crumbling under the pressure oh
for the ace and he's gonna take down
five to keep it alive for faze clan
twist the utility coming over top it's
his chance to shine a little bit of
damage double from twist he loses
carrick in the third fourth the magician
sprinkles a magic trick to the b site
did it open he reacts faster twist oh
baby what is that i was aggressive
player in 2018 and i definitely want to
go back to that
they're going to press hard into the pit
and dwight oh my god with a quick flick
of his wand they're all gone
[Applause]
to close this gap twist has been magical
concerns the sound is there the spray is
two he's got a second ak and he hits bin
off the bomb they have to run him down
simple's posted twist you've got no hope
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to ask you to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications if you
haven't done it yet it really helps and
then once you've done that you can help
us again by going to twitch.tv slash
core esports and giving us a follow
there we are going live all the time and
i'm telling you you don't want to miss a
stream okay so for a long time twist was
one of the pillars of nacs nitro's gone
as well and twist in the corner there
should be no way out my god how has he
done it picking up a quick triple and
he's going to win the round
he got like he got his big break playing
as a stand-in for tsm and eventually got
a permanent position on the team hc
seems to fit on where's he gonna put it
there's twist just moving up finding two
make it three pulls out the deagle
looking for the fourth kill the sequence
and he will find it sick with the other
kill and it twists
this guy's legit twist on land twist
time on tsm ended when the entire roster
was released and then picked up by
misfits the canadian phenom spent three
months on that team before transitioning
to an org that arguably defined his
future in cs go team liquid as one of
the largest orgs in esports liquid was
twist's chance to represent n a on some
of cs go's biggest stages it's a dream
come true to be playing on team liquid
being a 17 year old player and playing
on a tier 1 team feels great
i feel like i'm actually youngest player
playing at this like like competition
levels makes me feel like i have
something to prove the first couple of
years came with their fair share of
strife
liquid did well at a few big
international events but they always
fell short at the majors there's still a
minute on the clock here great doing big
damage but nitro is completely exposed
at least 12 hp blind flash bangs ct's
guns everywhere
trained on him and it's mere to finish
things off who better than mia in that
game vegas squadron 12-16 team liquid
are out of the major they're two kills
away from doing it to getting back to a
grand final to facing off against simple
to facing off against na'vi as nitro
looks for a better angle awp he's got to
be so perfect he's got to find an
absolutely lovely shot a quick one of
that and magisk he's not going to repeat
that he's already shown his hand flash
time so well and he goes you can peek
back out and there's no way twist wins
against four astralis with 16-7 and a
2-0
though for twists both the triumphs and
the failures were valuable practice
every experience good or bad let him
grow and develop his skills until twist
was arguably the absolute best cs go
player in na twist's raw aim was
actually so incredible his headshot
percentage was up there with the likes
of scream making twists one of the most
talented cs go players in the world
we'll trade straight back and hell races
being caught from the side this twist
comes through with two it should be a
third and he connects that additionally
he's just creeping up bomb is not
planted yet this two on two could die
for liquid if twist goes down and how
does if he misses a shot here he's
pretty much gone enough does he want to
get in there and help him he's thinking
about it oh my god
doesn't even take the pete just drops
him through the box and now glaive alone
37 seconds
getting a bit of a chance to reload it
again and he's gonna shut them down a
triple for twist on the end of the rush
out for twist dupreeh he's gonna be
blind twist gets he open and kill the
disc he has to respond but he's also
completely flashed twist doubles down
with the m4 and device on the side
misses a shot nitro doesn't realize
liquid still with two members up though
and even though device has side control
there's two players ready to chase him
down steel twice around the corner but
device is too fast and twist
oh what a pre-fired device dead that can
twist to even do this the players are
low zip nick's tagged up and glaive on
seven hp this is so doable for twist
of this one or two he's gonna try and
spot glaive does spot the head he knows
where one of these players are dave
takes the peak and he's gone down now
it's a 1v1 the ace is so close but zipex
is wrapped all the way around up to
apartments twist has no idea back
against him he's spotting him though and
twist he's gonna do it he gets the ace
and hugo how on earth does he manage
that of course every great player needs
a great team if they want to win and a
few roster shuffles later liquid finally
found the perfect lineup they weren't
quite ready for the spotlight in time
for 2019's first major in katowice but
when the summer rolled around liquid
went on an absolute tear winning back to
back to back tournament becoming the
second ever team to win the intel grand
slam and the million dollar prize went
with it all in just 63 days the holy
chalice now belongs to team liquid and
so much more four from four
accomplishments are transient but this
legacy is permanent they have done what
no one might ever do again until grand
slam team liquid
for a short while liquids incredible
performance put north american
counter-strike back on the map
unfortunately their momentum came to an
end just before the berlin major and it
was pretty much all downhill from there
i think the thing was like we didn't
really know why we we fell so hard after
the break and like things just didn't
feel
the same and like everyone could really
feel it three versus one and lisa has to
deliver again can he save the day it
comes down to this moment and it looks
something might be done and the phone be
the future
and it's going to be 16-13 we say
goodbye to team liquid and hell up to
the grand final for us
an epic map to close out this semi-final
zipex working up the ladder and device
already wanting to come in through mini
an excellent flash zip x takes him down
it's all on naf
ice in his veins can he handle this heat
bomb is tapped not planted for him he's
got it down to the 1v1 zfx could very
well clutch this if he sticks it no way
to knock out liquid the bombs ticking
away at quite the pace twist does have
the kit he thinks he's got a good idea
swings
the semi-finals and they smashed the
curse of win versus liquid and then
covet hit sending all of cs go on a line
and liquids results further into the
toilet nitro their igl became the first
casualty of liquids fall from grace
twist hung on for a few more months but
the writing was on the wall for his
floundering team bliss had every reason
to ditch north america big orbs were
pulling out of the nac any competition
worth talking about was happening on
european servers and not to mention the
fact that his girlfriend is german it
seemed like all roads led to europe and
twists decided it was time for a big
move i actually have a
an announcement to make
on the back of ending 2020 on a very
uh good final it was the matchup that i
could have hoped for
um that was actually my last games with
team liquid and
that could be exciting to to some people
or very bad news for a lot of liquid
fans
but i just wanted them to hear it from
me
[Music]
twists considered several options when
it came to picking his next team but
ultimately he settled on faze clan
partially because the team decided to
bring back their once ousted superstar
igl carrigan the first timers in phase
was really good results and in the end
we won't run away from winning the major
so that's something i'll come back to to
fix for twists playing with a new team
was also an opportunity to write some of
the wrongs from his time on a liquid
yeah i would like to go back to like my
my 2018 self where you know if i needed
to pick up the op if i felt like it was
a necessary thing then you know i'll do
that you know i had like a lot of
freedom
to do whatever to make myself feel
comfortable and do whatever i need to do
to make my team feel comfortable
and i was entering a lot i was
aggressive player in 2018 and i
definitely want to go back to that and
going to europe was a huge risk no big
name north american player had ever made
the jump to a european team twist's move
was unheard of but just because faze
represented a chance to do great things
didn't mean the team got off to a hot
start and they again have time to set
this up they can do that cheeky smoke
that helps you to get out on this
balcony then i'm gonna do that just
running right in his neck so he gets the
kill continues to spray and that is it
16 to five as they bring down phase on
that third and final map
oh and in the smoke i think they may
have been blocked what is that
nonsense from yuri and this one is just
a sad state of affairs it's beautiful
from fury
and that's the way it finishes could it
be more convincing
just two players left all that's
stopping them
from moving forward dexter wants to take
the peak and as the swing comes in twist
is good for one day can't get more it's
mouse boards to take it away and it'll
be faze clan eliminated last place from
the dreamhack master spring one of
faze's biggest disappointments was an
early exit from the stockholm major now
he's faked out a couple of steps toward
the bathroom where he made noise but
they know he's not in that direction
because already buster is clearing that
buster has that information and this
should be pretty straightforward from vp
they'll smoke him off as well it gets
worse he goes through to find one but
wasn't expecting two and flink gets the
final kill vertice pro not only come
back in this series they dominated and
so close to phase it's heartbreak no
doubt but they are in the playoffs the
rest of the year was similarly
underwhelming but a new addition was
about to make a huge difference it's
really tough to have a player that's not
him
to replace olaf you know it's the
perfect
it's literally a perfect fit and it
would have been a disaster i think to
not have him but
depending or not you know maybe jks
would have been a good option too
but robs is literally the perfect fit
for this team romps turned out to be
exactly what faze needed they hit the
ground running in 2022 and win after win
catapulted them into the top spot in the
hltv world rankings favin kills kerrigan
jump up from the ladder into the meat
grinder crossfire for the end and phase
well deserved yes sir there's no other
options for g2
aka picked back up by alex cbb but he
was tagged in the process hunter instead
they'll get jks
he's still here oh they lined up he's
actually hit one plus two he did damage
that's gonna drop them down a dollar
hunter and it's all over twice with the
final care and phase finally stays
finally on the stage and count events it
will take a championship and you can see
what it means to kerrigan as he falls to
his knees yeah they're so locked in they
have to know it as well brokey is going
to grab the angle with an awp he's not
going to shy away step around that smoke
blinded a little bit but surely he's
going to come back for it all of faze
ready to fight there's the flashbang
broke he's got one more and there's rain
faze have done it they take the series
three to one and faze are gonna be your
champions every step of the way whether
his team won or not twists was popping
heads this guy was born in lower moulded
by it
he didn't see zaiwa two he's nearly a
man and it's
blinded five on two ready to shut this
map out there might be one man to do it
twist it's a dark knight indeed for
vitality ace for twist twist will be
immediately found
and taken down they'll even elevate
their positions twist trying to use the
gap to see through spots seize them easy
find of the kill looks down hunter not
looking the right way and twist has both
let him drop down onto the hate card
kerrigan comes running outwards now
twist is going to execute
two three and faze take that legend spot
a well-deserved label but of course the
pinnacle of success in cs go is winning
a major faze went into the antwerp major
as the obvious favorites and for twists
this was a chance to accomplish
something he'd never be able to do if he
stayed in na the legend stage went
predictably smoothly with phase
qualifying 3-1 for champions now twist
had just three teams standing between
him and the top including last year's
major winners na'vi simple is the
greatest player to ever touch cs go and
the rest and avi are intimidating too
but twist and faze were ready to take
their major
now that they get those two steps closer
do they just want to take this they're
gonna press hard into the pit it twists
oh my god with a quick flick of his wand
they're all gone
man advantage for phases they push into
this site and he's the tight coward
they are done
the prophecy is foretold the favorite
twin and here it is both players might
back them back in this side broken with
one
follows up it's a 1v1
[Applause]
he's going huge
necessary damage done
can they convert
up against it up against the ropes
simple electronic though not to be
underestimated rookie door he's out of
the round
he takes another and no no
it could be 55 still the t side required
to gain access to a site the options
plentiful
and brave he's not done he gets his
thirty and faze two
frags away
[Applause]
honestly it's a special feeling to to
win a major in my career so early on
and uh there's no other team that i
would want to accomplish it with
uh these guys are family to me and uh
i'll never forget these moments with
them seriously
twists took a huge gamble when he moved
to europe i mean moving to another
continent is already a massive
undertaking but twist didn't just leave
north america he also said goodbye to a
team he was part of for more than three
years at just 21 years old he packed up
and moved across the ocean to take a
chance on a roster that was unlike any
he's ever played on before he endured a
year of uncertainty and mediocre results
all because he believed he made the
right choice and twist cemented his
position as one of the greatest players
na has ever produced when phase one iem
cologne thanks in part to his incredible
plays in the grand finals one of the
most dominant individual performances in
cs go history to close this gap twist
has been magical
concerns the sound is there the spray is
two he's got a second ak hey and he hits
bin off the bomb they have to run him
down simples posted twist you've got no
hope
[Applause]
he's like the aggression he's been found
out before and twists talk about his
impact this would be some time to find
out the right in the hole do you
consider that he did it
and he slaps him down back in the skull
breaks navy's backs
in the dying stages of regulation as
they're gone
15.
he did it once
surely he can't hold his nerve
in another impossible clutch three
members of phase they won't let this go
they will not go quietly
[Applause]
[Music]
is proof that there is life after nacs
and that sometimes taking a leap of
faith can turn out better than you could
have ever imagined
twist time twists time on tsm and what
twists time is really hard to say
it does actually you want a twist time
also it could also be a children's show
like on tree house
yeah twist time
it seems like more like a nickelodeon
one like it seems like a very wacky kind
of show